when the pandemic struck i mean my book
came out a few months before the
pandemic and so for from a from for
someone like me who like who loves to
observe and like whether this stuff is
true or not you know you sort of go
you know you sort of wonder is
everything going to hold up or not
and as an existential flex
is something that i predicted would
happen either zero once or at the
absolute most twice in a career but when
covet happened we all went through it at
the same time existential flexibility is
is that you're able to make a profound
uh 180 degree strategic shift in order
to continue to advance your cause in
other words stay relevant
um
this is not about the daily flexibility
of business this is we're talking
profound strategic shift here um and
sometimes brought on by pandemic
sometimes brought on by changing
technology or politics or culture or
tastes
um but you're able to adjust
um so for example it's um apple steve
jobs when they're developing technology
in one direction
they just and they discover this thing
called the graphic user interface that
they did not invent and they decided to
walk away from millions of dollars spent
and
countless man hours in order to focus on
a different uh strategic uh
position because jobs believe that that
was a better way to advance his cause of
empowering individuals to use uh
personal computers
um that's that's existential flexible